all right shorty yes shorty uh where'd
you grew up where are you from
originally i grew up in east l.a um i'm
originally from white fence
which is a street gang yes it is
and tell me about your childhood
well i i started i be i got into white
fence when i was uh nine years old
um
at the time i was looking for a family
so
um
they were my family but now i turn
around and i look and they're nowhere to
be found
i feel like i'm all alone
out here where were your parents before
you were nine years old
my father passed away
and
my mom remarried and
my stepfather used to hit me a lot
and then my mother started hitting me a
lot
so that's when i left
and uh i've been all
on my own since then
um
i stayed with my street mom
i'm not that far from here um we
she
she used to uh push a cart back
thank you
back in the days um
on wabash she used to push her cart
and she's always i
i was staying with her living with her
before she's william she's
so she became she's just like mom
she's a mom i never had um she showed me
a lot
she
i said i i say she's my mom
because
it doesn't take one to make a child
i think it takes one um
once one you could you could
you you
you raised and take care of
so on mother's day
i only
saw her i didn't even talk to my mother
not that i didn't want to or i didn't
try but
there was there was no answer
so the only person that i celebrated
was hit with was her
and you live on the streets here on row
yes they they took my children away i
have 10 children i have
10 10 girls and um
i'm 46 years old
they took them away from me because
they felt that i wasn't putting the
child in danger
and with me being out in the street
well one day i tried a pcp and i woke up
in jail
on a murder trial can you believe that
i was found guilty um
my
biological mother
she
hired a
a murder lawyer and
if
if i was ever to see the daylight ever
again she would give my children to me i
signed them over because they told me
would i rather them go with
with my family or would i rather them go
with a stranger and i picked my mother
well what
promises are made to be broken because
when i did see the daylight
because they said if if if
if if if the
if
if it was found outside the property
she's found not guilty if it's inside
the property then she's found guilty and
it was outside the property so i got a
no no no guilty plea
public pretender found me guilty of
course
they always do how much time did you do
i did six years on that um
i
i was remember anything about that
murder excuse me do you remember
anything about that i don't remember too
much no
i just remember uh
what started it was my daughter's she's
31 years old and she's handicapped and
she came up to me and she said
mommy when you were in prison
i got raped
i just
just went crazy
she was raped so bad she can't have
children which i can't
i can't have no grandkids um
so but we have marquee
and she has a
her little dolls
two dolls
and she calls him there's your like my
grandsons
and pokemon is my grandson too
so
um
she's she's right now she's in a
transitional
living living
i wanted to be better than me i don't
want her to
to be out here the way i used i always
tower every day
you don't want to be like mom you don't
you know
one time
we were having a birthday party for her
and there was a dj
my mom's husband it just sucked me well
when they came in they saw me
hit him my daughter him
and my daughter daughter came in with my
mother
and i already knew that what was going
to happen when my mom told me stop me
stop don't don't you're going to hurt
him i was like how how am i going to do
that
so
of course like always i had to leave
that was probably the hardest thing i
ever did
but like i told my daughter to go on and
have a nice time and
i'll be okay
she always uh
calls me and asks mommy are you
are you okay please promise me
and i
i laugh sometimes
i want to cry or i'm crying
because i haven't either ate or
or slaved or i'm tired
or
you know things things that happen out
here
um
and i have to
make it seem like i'm okay
because i don't want her to worry she
doesn't need to worry
not somebody like her she she doesn't i
don't feel that she doesn't she doesn't
deserve that
um
i just feel bad that
i couldn't give her you know what
she needed
you know a good family
but
the best i could do is where she's at
um
do you remember anything about your
early childhood
i just remember the beatings i remember
that i remember when um
when my stepdad used to get mad i
remember running and hiding
and i remember when he found me one time
that was
that was beating in my lifetime
um
i just remember the meetings for my mom
i don't really remember
i think i wanted to forget about it so
forget about those bad days those days
because it was never any happy days
so much that
i just don't remember them you have no
happy memories of your childhood none at
all
do you feel loved ever is it no i don't
no
it's it's it's it's
ruined i tried getting married that
didn't work
i
i can't get into a relationship because
it doesn't work
i don't know
people tell me something's wrong with
you
they really messed you up you're all
messed up inside you you don't even know
how i how do you want me to love you if
i don't even love myself
how how is that possible
so
and i and i'm i came this
like if i say this way
which i've been everywhere of
because my my my my mom lives down not
that far from here
and um
but she
she wanted me to come stay with her
because she wanted me to get off the
streets finally
she said i'm off the streets i don't
want i want you to be off the streets
too she goes
we could have a door now
and and it's very true
it's very true but
like the way i am
i
come and go
and
i've gone
i asked to get me to be married
very many times and i
everybody laughs
she'll never marry nobody
you're crazy for her love somebody if
she should she i don't
and when when anybody sees me i'm
walking alone or i'm alone
nobody ever sees me
maybe they see me with the dog now but
that's about it
and i say i tell people that
you might you might i don't talk to
people very much
or i don't hang around with people very
much
people i'll say hi to people or or
you know here and there and
then i go
i guess
it's just i don't know sometimes i just
don't even understand it
they say for me to go to psychiatrists
what am i supposed to choose
tell them all this story they have did
it's not even written in the book
even if they if even if it is i don't
think that they can they have to really
experience it to know
exactly what it is like out here
because it does get cold and it does get
lonely yeah
and it's a terrible lifestyle for
especially for a female right yeah yeah
it's
you know a female supposed to
have a life you know uh not be on the
streets or
just live the life that i lived you know
a lot of people could put things aside
and go on with their lives and i just
can't seem to do that
you feel like you belong down here
or it's home it's comfortable
yeah it's the environment i guess of
this these are this these are the areas
that i've been through been been around
like
i'll be around these kind of areas you
stay in the tent
yes i do
yes have my tent and tell my mom i'm
standing right here with my mom but i do
have the tent
um what is your drug now
uh his methamphetamine
yeah i used to be very very very bad on
about cocaine
and i think i started using the reason
why i started using the drugs was
because i was trying to hide this pain i
couldn't take this pain away i felt so i
started cutting myself
and
it if anybody wants to say it doesn't
hurt it hurts
it's just the pain was more like
i was i was
they say that it the pain it releases
the the the the pain you have inside
but when it it for what a second
the the pain is so great that you're not
thinking about the painia okay that's
understandable but what about after you
know
they still have it and for i know they
do because i sure did
um
i went to a to a mental uh uh exodus and
they
they uh they diagnosed me as bipolar
schizophrenia
well if you've been out here so many
years won't you be bipolar schizophrenia
i have
you know
i wake up like
i i i'll fight i'll fight in my sleep
or i tell somebody off in my sleep that
people are scared of me when i'm they're
like you're mean you're mean for i said
i'm not mean what do you talk they said
yeah you should have seen me when you
were sleeping you got up told me off and
went back to sleep
and and i'm i'm
just i've been out here for so long when
somebody just touches me i'll freak out
you know
i
i freak out
how far did you go in school
i went up to the eighth grade
i only went up to eighth grade um
i i tried i went i tried to go back to
school i went to icdc college i was
pregnant at the time
but i had just gotten out of prison i
said i was going to make something of
myself and i tried
and i did graduate from that but i just
didn't things just didn't work out i
came right back to the streets
my mom would try to my real mom would
try to
get me off this
to stay put and i could i just can't
i don't know what it is i don't know if
these streets call me or
what is it
and now that i'm very very tired it's
like
i can't even get out of here
now now that i really really want to
just look at how can i get out
i just
i get
there's just it's just impossible
do you think you'd be uncomfortable in a
situation with a nice
apartment
and a job and a car and a
would i be uncomfortable i
i want to be uncomfortable
i want to be uncomfortable i it's
something that i
i want now
but back then i couldn't
i didn't want it i think i think i
wanted this
now i don't want i just don't want i'm
tired i'm so tired
you know
what what i would do just to
to have exactly what you said
i would give up just give up my own my
own life for that what do you do for
money no
um
well i'm not very proud to say
but um
i learned how to make a
a dollar
into a hundred dollars and
it's better than standing out in the
corner
that i've always said
it's more of a hard life
to dealing with that
and it's and it's very very very very
very lonely
if if somebody says what they do
if they say that this isn't only their
kid they're lying
and there's only one result to this
and
that's either being institutionalized
death
or
or
just a present you know there's no
there's no
there's nothing good about this
and
i know this
and
i'm 46 years old and look at me and it
feels like i'm really beginning it's
just
if you had to point the finger what
set you on this path would you say it
was just a
lack of parenting
i think it was like a parenting the way
i was raised
what the beatings i went through the
loyal the way
my mom chose
him over her belief
him instead of believing me and then i
took the beatings from him and then she
started beating me i was just
i always i used to be so angry i have a
lot of anger and i used to say she put
me out here you know my mom did this to
me
why did they why did they even have me
why were they so cruel to have me and
throw me out here like this
well when my father passed on that's
when it all began
that's when i left and i ended up being
for my fence
my father never wanted me to grow up
like this and i know he's probably
twinning in his grave today
knowing that i'm where i am
but there's always one thing he told me
he said uh
take care of your mom
tell the last thing he said
take care of your mom please make sure
that she's okay
so i do do that
i i asked her if she's okay but
sometimes i know she's not
i could hear it in her voice and i said
mom please tell me if you're i never ask
my mom for money
because i know she won't give it to me
and i know she has it but she will not
give it to me even if she knows
that i'm hungry or
that
you know i i don't have anything it does
not mandatory or i have nowhere to
sleep
this doesn't say i use
they used to tell me it was it would be
tough love you know it's tough love but
i don't believe that that's tough enough
if if if if my child was out here in the
street and my child needed money for
food or shelter i'm pretty sure i know
for a fact i will give it to my child if
i had it
but why does she do what she does
i just don't know
i can't explain it because i just don't
know
everybody tells me it's tough love but
they can't be here
i don't
see her for christmas i don't
see her for a mother's day or in any any
vacations it's just another day to me
maybe maybe it's a
celebration to everybody but it's just
another day out here for me
um
do you have friends out here uh-huh do
you have friends
i i have i have a lot of friends
i choose not to be around them
why because
it seemed to be life seemed to be more
harder
they want basically they want if they
want they want whatever you have meaning
they want to be in your shoes why i
don't know why
i i just
don't understand it and i don't think i
would ever unders these issues you would
not want to fit in you do not want to be
in them and if you walked in them i'm
pretty sure you would throw them away
so the only thing that i have is this
little puppy
huh and the other one ran away from me
i maybe maybe it's maybe it's a better
thing because
he needs a home and he needs a place
where he runs around and
and i can't give it to him
so i just want to make sure that he's
okay
he's in a place that they're going to
take care of him you know have you been
in love in your life
um
i i was in love one to one i can't say i
i don't even know what love is to tell
you the truth i
i could say that i was
i think i was but
i really don't know i don't even know
what it is to tell you it's true i don't
i have no idea what love is
i've never been
loved
or
um
you describe yourself as lonely
yes very
yeah very very um
and just just last night was one of them
it was very was wonderful
that's why i was a little bit running a
little bit late and and i had this
little one with me because i was
running after
my dog and he's she's a
she's a uh
she she detects my seizures see i was
being on the head so bad that
i had sustained a head trauma and i
started having seizures so now i have
seizures all my life really i could do
the head drama
um
my memory is not too good because due to
this fact for head trauma
oh i lost some of my memory so
and they said it's gonna get worse i
i
sometimes it's true because i don't
remember anything
and then things will come to me and then
i'll forget them again
or i'm doing something and i forget what
i'm doing
it's like
i actually forgot what i was doing
and it's very it's not good out here to
let anybody know that you'll forget what
you're doing
or to let them know that
your fingers broke your arms broke like
my finger it's messed up i broke it
and i took the cast off too early and it
hurts me so bad i mean
but
i don't i don't want them to anybody to
know that's why i took it all
because
these people they what they see is
they see
a weakness on you and that's what
they're going to go for
so if you're say if you had a broken arm
they see you with a broken arm they're
going to get they're going to hit you on
your your arm
that's how they're going to get you down
if you show weakness you're not going to
make it out here it's rough because
that's what that that they're just
existence here surrounded by snakes and
hustlers once i walk out of this door
it's
it's it's
it's a zoo out there it's it's crazy out
there
if
sometimes
i thank god for every day i wake up
um
like they say tomorrow's never promised
in my life
but the next second isn't ever promised
i could be here right now i'd be talking
to you and
then the next 10 minutes i could be gone
um
i just always worry about
these ones
taking care of these puppies
um my my street mom
uh told me if something happened to her
she's i'm to take care of weta
well my service dog my service dog
that's that's the one that i was going
after
um
i
went on and my service dog don't get
along
he's
she's he's a husky she's he's really big
he's too big for
he's just too big so
he i took it to the babysitters and he
ran away from the babysitters he's been
gone for three months
i found him in compton i don't know how
he got way out there
i felt so sorry for him
now i know the way
i mean i know what that dog was going
through
and
i tackled him and i said i hope he
remembers me because if he don't he's
going to bite my head off
and when i tackled him i hesitated a
little bit i did
but i went for it because i didn't want
him i didn't want to want him to live
the life i lived out here poor thing he
he you could tell he was he was tired
he was dehydrated uh
i took him to the vet
and
i spent just a little bit of
i didn't even eat that day because i
took him to the vet
and
he had a little urine infection and um
he was very stressed very stressed
that's why he was losing his coat
and that's why i say maybe it's it's
best that i want him to be in a good
place a good home if
if i can't give it to him
i don't feel that he should have to live
that life
and then that's an animal
um
i don't feel that anybody has to live
this way
how does this life affect you
emotionally
emotionally um now you see me crying i
don't let nobody see me cry
um out here we don't cry
that's just
out there we just don't
but inside we all are crying
every one of us that you see out here
we have a lot of crying inside of us
well i cry all the time
but you just don't see it no nobody sees
it i'll put on glasses sunglasses
so
but it is not it's a jungle out there
and once i step out that's
going into the war zone out there what's
your biggest fear
my biggest fear is that i'm gonna die
out here which most likely i am
but my biggest fear is that they're
going to throw me
aside like
a piece of crap you know
and nobody's going to be around to claim
me
that's
what scares me
because if you die out here that's
exactly what happened
either they don't claim you or they
can't find you or
or there's nothing to find
but and i just don't want that
i want i want
i had i had 10 beautiful children and
i didn't raise them
but um
i wish i could have do you talk to them
still
i've
it's been a year i haven't spoken to
them tell you the truth i haven't spoken
to them once since about two years after
i got out of prison
it's been about 14 years now um
my mom
my real mom she keeps in contact with
them but they're all over 18 stuff
and they're good children i always i
always told them that you don't want to
be like mom you know mommy's not here
but where's mommy
they'll say mommy's in my heart
oh yeah maybe i'll always be in your
heart
if i could have my children
i would
that would
that would be probably
i see people out here
i just don't understand
people out here
if they could go see their children why
why don't they i just don't understand
it
but
they don't have no clue what
it is to not have them
and i think shame is a big part of why
that happens well they got to put that
aside and
they got to be their parent teach them
to love you no matter
who you how you were raised or who you
are you're their mom and their dad
and i think every child
deserves to know who their parents are
and
that's one thing i think about all the
time
mom
they asked for me the three oldest ones
they remember me
and they
my mom told them that i passed away
and i don't think i don't feel that
that's right
and some way maybe
i did
so sometimes i feel that way
but the only thing that keeps me going
is this little puppy
um
a straight mom that's somebody
that's about it
that would be my
my whole family you know
that's
what my street mom she says uh
you and what are the only ones that i
got
i said well that makes makes two of us
you know
you're the only one that i got
and
she's like me
we love our we love our animals because
that's all we have
and
and just like her if it was for me to
eat or the or the puppy to eat it would
be the puppy first
and she's done the same and i've done
the same so
shorty what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
the life i learned in life is to never
give up your children
and these drugs in these streets aren't
that important
one of these days you'll find yourself
out here alone
and when you turn around
children aren't going to be around
it's going to be too late to get them
and when it's too late
it's it's just too late
see children one thing they don't do is
they don't stop growing
so it's not like you have much time it's
it's just get if i could sometimes if i
could just get get the mom and maybe i
don't know what i have to do
but just so they could see for a minute
how important this is
but
i've tried to talk to i tucked my ears
out one time
and all i got was
why are you telling her it's not like
she's not listening it's going out there
one ear out through the other oh wow
well then
you're wasting your time i said that's
all i got is time
what does it matter if i could
if if sitting here talking to her
telling her something positive for her
to do
for for
for me if that's what that's what for
her just being sitting here
listening to me is it meaning something
i go i don't know maybe she might walk
away and it might
help her maybe won't i
i'll never know
but
i know
maybe god
i just wouldn't
i i i don't i don't ever
say okay what i said to this person is
and how i just walk away and i say god
please help her
please help her before she ends up where
i'm at
and i tell her if you if i could i just
have just what you got do you know what
i would do for that
just one more one more chance
i wouldn't be i wouldn't have to be out
here talking to you
i said
you got the chance to get your children
back get your life back why do you
why do you want to throw it all away why
do you want it what's out here that's
better than that
but what is what's better
the drugs
the streets you're gonna get tired of it
trust me i i thought that that was more
important than anything in my children
in my whole life
and look at me now
what i would do just to go back and
change things and i can't
one thing you can't do is go back in
time and change things
and i wish i could but you can't
i don't think i would be sitting here
today
i'm talking to you if i did
so
all right shorty thank you so much for
sharing your story
i wish you and your new puppy
thank you thank you
hey
and you were asleep the whole time yeah
you